what's up guys welcome back to some
titanfall 2 videos and today we're going
to be starting a new series on my
channel where I go through all six
Titans in titanfall 2 and I explain to
you their weapons their personal gadgets
how they stack up against the
competition meaning their counters in
who they counter and how to fight a or
how to fight as them whether you're
fighting a Titan or you're fighting
multiple pilots
so before we get into the weapons and
personal gadgets let's give a little
back story about tone-tone is a female
chassis with a medium build medium
health and medium speed meaning this is
kind of the middle titan if you don't
really want to go with more speed and
less health or more health and less
speed this is kind of a middle type of
titan to figure out what you prefer
better next we're going to be talking
about is the weapons the only weapon
that tone has is a 40-millimeter tracker
cannon which fires semiauto my auto
explosive rounds that you should
definitely know if you played the first
titanfall the next I'm going to be
talking about is personal gadgets for
this Titan now each Titan has the
titanfall kit their personal kit and a
Titan kit we're not going to be talking
about the Titan kit or the titanfall kit
because each Titan has the same one
we're going to talk about it's personal
kit now tone has four different
abilities the enhanced tracker rounds
which critical hits applied to tracker
marks on targets the particle wall
reinforced is a particle wall that lasts
longer and blocks more damage the pulse
echo which after a short delay sonar
pulse echoes the second pulse and the
rocket barrage which is tracker rockets
fired two additional miss now we're
going to talk about tones abilities tone
has four different types of abilities as
his tighten his left bumper ability on
xbox is the particle wall where he
blocks damage from one side book and
shoot out the other his right bumper is
a tracking rocket when fully locked on
he can fire up to i think five missiles
at a target he has his Y button which
reveals enemy is a Sona Lockridge
revealed enemies in the area which
includes a I pilot and Titans and then
his ultimate or core ability is the
salvo core which launches a barrage of
rockets to where tone points they will
always follow your cursor now that all
the data has been given about tone and
his and her class and what she does I
have devised the best class to use as
tone
you wanted to stick to the tone for the
tone kit you want to stick with the
rocket barrage because seeing as the
Rockets when fully loaded are do enough
damage as it is you want to have more
rockets which means more damage now that
we've gone over tones abilities let's
talk about how to use tone when you're
fighting another Titan now yes there is
five other Titans and even if you fight
another tone it could be a problem but
this is just your general basis when you
fight tone you want to be as far or when
you fight as tone you want to be as far
away as you can from the other Titan put
up your particle shield and pick him off
if he starts running away pop your sonar
lock so you can track his location and
hopefully you can get your tracking
rockets to be fully locked on and you
can shoot some rockets to chase him
while he runs away the last thing you
want to do is tone is to use the salvo
core the only time you ever want to use
the salvo core is when you are
outnumbered by other Titans if it's a
two-on-one situation launch the salvo
core at the either the highest priority
or the lowest health Titan to get him
out of the fight so it's an even one on
one now that we've talked about tones
abilities and how to use her as a Potter
as a Titan let's talk about her counters
she is amazing against low health Titans
such as North Star and Ronan she can
pick them off do a couple tracking
rockets and they'll be out in an instant
the two that she does not like is scorch
and Legion Legion has the ability to
unload a minigun rule minigun clip into
her from a long distance and he's got a
gun shield so you're tracking rockets
are useless Legion also an Legion and
scorch also have the most amount of
health in the game and seeing as you're
a medium Titan you already have less
health as it is so once again the whole
staying away from them will really help
out well now that we've gone through
everything about tone I hope you guys
have enjoyed this is a super interesting
video for me to make and I'm going to be
making them for all the other five
Titans I just need to experiment with
them more
I've been doing a lot with Ronan and
scorch I haven't really touched
northstar ion and Legion I haven't even
touched either but i will be getting to
that in the next coming days so be on
the lookout for that anyway guys if you
did enjoy please leave a like and
comment and then if you're new around
here subscribe because i'm going to be
putting more of these out as they as i
develop them regardless guys have a nice
day in peace